[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
image compression and the fast Fourier
transform and in this lecture I'm going
to show you how you can do an even
better job often times by using the
wavelet transform for image compression
okay so this is going to be a MATLAB
version of this lecture so instead of
FFT we're going to be using the wavelet
transform that we've discussed in
previous lectures and instead of FFT 2
here and I FFT we're basically going to
be doing the continuous R sorry the
discrete wavelet transform and the
inverse wavelet transform and these are
built into MATLAB and Python so you can
kind of get working on this really
really quickly
ok so we're gonna do the same image
representation problem of my dog
Mordecai so we're gonna load the dog I'm
going to show you what the wavelet
transform looks like on Mort and then
we're going to use this for compression
ok so that's all coming up ok good and
I'm gonna show you this a couple of
different ways so again we're just going
to read in the dog we're gonna turn this
into a greyscale image and then in this
line 6 we're going to compute the
wavelet decomposition so this is a
two-level wavelet decomposition and
equals 2 and we're gonna use the dobisch
e1 wavelet which is just one of many
many many types of wavelets you can use
we could replace this with a horror
wavelet coil it's all kinds of different
wavelets you can choose from ok so
really simple and then what I'm going to
do is most of this is actually just for
kind of so this once I compute this
wavelet decomposition all of that
information is going to be stored in
these C and s objects and then you're
going to basically pull out of those
coefficients in see the different
approximation at level one and all the
kind of matrices for for these
coefficients and so you should look at
the documentation of
Dec to wave wave lit decomposition the
to means that this is for a two-by-two
array rather than a one dimensional
signal
sorry now a two-by-two array an array
with with basically a matrix this is for
a matrix instead of for a one
dimensional signal and then we're gonna
pull out all of the information from
level 1 level 2 if this was an N equals
3 a 3 level decomposition we'd have the
same code for level 3 and so on and so
forth and here I'm just gonna plot some
of these matrices for you and you can
see what the wavelet decomposition looks
like ok so I'm going to load Mort run
the wavelet decomposition and this is
this is what you get so there's a lot
going on here I'm going to try to walk
you through this but this is a very kind
of shallow treatment of the wavelet
decomposition so you're gonna have to
dig a little deeper and read some
documentation if you really want to
figure out what all these matrices mean
and how to use them but the basic idea
this is kind of a coarse version of the
image so I had a high-res image and
essentially the first thing we're gonna
do is kind of get a coarse-grained low
res version of that image and then each
of these levels are going to be
corrections to that low resolution
version of Mort okay so you're basically
going to take to this you're gonna add
these little features and then to that
you're gonna add these little features
and you're gonna get more and more kind
of resolution by by taking this low
coarse grainy image and then adding
these refinement features ok and you'll
notice that these refinements are mostly
black they're mostly zeros are nearly
zero and then all of the kind of
refinement is focused on regions where
you need more resolution so like
whiskers eyes places where there's a lot
going on in the image and so that's nice
because what that means is that you're
only storing kind of this low res
information and then you can zero out
all the the black or nearly black
elements of this wavelet decomposition
and you only have to save information in
this refinement region
and so I'm gonna kind of zoom in here
just to give you a picture of what one
of these okay so this is kind of a zoom
in on some of the features that you
might that you might refine okay so back
in the day if you loaded images you know
on a slow modem you'd see them line by
line kind of raster load okay and now
what you see when you have an image a
really high-resolution image loading and
maybe you have a slow internet
connection what you'll see is it'll
start off with a really coarse grain II
kind of blocky version of the image so
very low res and then every once in a
while it'll get another level of the
wavelet decomposition loaded and so
it'll refine some some of that image and
add a little bit of detail and then
it'll load some you know another level
of the wavelet decomposition and you'll
see even more features come in to crisp
focus and so instead of the old days of
kind of raster loading of images now you
can actually see the compression
algorithm sometimes when you have a slow
internet connection because your image
will load one level of the wavelet
decomposition at a time and it'll
actually see features kind of come into
focus so maybe you've never seen that
before but now that I've told you you'll
see it if you ever have like a low
bandwidth internet connection and you're
trying to load you know a
high-resolution image okay so that
definitely happens okay good so that's a
very very shallow kind of treatment of
what the wavelet decomposition in matlab
does and some of the ways you can pull
this apart you can see there's a lot of
information here so I definitely
recommend you check out the
documentation kind of read up on this if
you want to actually use this for
anything and you know try different
different wavelets try a horror wavelet
try try other kinds of wavelets and see
if they do better or worse and how they
perform there is a nice code you can
download on on the the mathworks
exchange called plot wavelet - that
basically does everything i did in my
previous code but in one line so if you
run this code it basically generates
that low res image and then all of these
wavelet refinements
at higher higher resolution so I think
that's kind of nice
okay good so finally what we're gonna do
is we're going to use this for
compression so just like in the Fourier
transform we found that many many of
those Fourier coefficients were nearly
zero and we could throw them away we're
gonna do the exact same thing in the
wavelet transformation so lots of those
coefficients are nearly zero and we can
throw them away and still have a really
faithful representation of our original
image in fact that's the basis of the
JPEG 2000 image compression it's kind of
a better version of Fourier compression
using wavelets it's wavelet compression
okay so same exact thing as before we're
gonna have our dog we're gonna compute a
in this case four layer wavelet
decomposition so we're gonna have kind
of really coarse and then medium higher
and highest resolution refinements and
just like before what we're gonna do is
we're going to sort these wavelet
coefficients again this is a big array
of wavelet coefficients we're gonna sort
those and we're going to keep the first
10% the first 5% the first one percent
and the first point five percent largest
wavelet coefficients and threshold
everything else out to zero and see how
good those images are even when we
massively compress and throw away as
many wavelets coefficients as we can
okay so basically just like the Fourier
image compression example except now
we're doing wavelet decomposition so I'm
going to run this and we're going to see
kind of my dog mort at different levels
of wavelet compression okay now if
you're doing this at home I would highly
encourage you to do to run this code and
also to run the FFT to version of this
code where you compress using the
Fourier transform and kind of do a
head-to-head comparison to see at one
percent which of these images actually
looks better okay so that's that's
really the the proofs in the pudding you
actually have to you know run this side
by side against the fast Fourier
transform version and see if I only keep
one percent of my wavelet coefficients
or one percent of my Fourier
coefficients which of these images looks
better now I think that actually the
wavelet compression is doing a much
better
job here this is more faithfully
capturing fine resolution details of
Mort you know his tail and the whiskers
and and you know what I would consider
high resolution or high frequency
components like fur and hair and edges
that's what wavelets are really good at
is capturing those kinds of things and
so at least I've convinced myself that
it looks better here okay now at point
five percent if you remember in the FFT
example I went all the way down to point
two percent but here if I go if I
compress too far in wavelets it all kind
of breaks down so I'm actually going to
show you if I only if I kept only point
zero two so if I go even farther what
you're gonna find is it's running now
I've like massively over compressed I've
killed major big features of Mort that
you know it's kind of garbage at this
point so that's a concern but I would
say that you know even keeping only the
first point five percent that's a 200
times compression and it looks really
really good you know very accurate
representation of Mort
okay good so that's image compression
using wavelets I encourage you to try
this out yourself it's super easy to use
yeah and you know try different
different wavelet and different mother
wavelets try you know haar wavelets and
koi Flitz and other other kinds and kind
of see how it works okay thank you